The Joe Rogan Experience the thing I'm
excited has to bring it back to my
stupid plug but the garden show uh I
haven't been I used to do it it was
normal
to do the garden for me before which is
not a good thing right like I remember
Chris Rock saying to me once after a
show at the Garden he's like you you
like this is like a club for you where
you try [__] out now because I did it
like five times in a week I just take
the subway to take the C train up do the
garden and leave like I don't party
after I just destroy it right right but
it's that went away and I hadn't been
there for a while but now to me this one
show there's like this very exciting
thought yeah to just do one and the set
of prepared for it is not a rock star
set it's it's pretty gritty it's pretty
I mean it all kills it's similar to what
I saw at the creek yeah I've been
working on it since so there's a lot of
new stuff yeah but it's
um the idea of being surrounded by these
18 000 people in this in this Elite
Arena
saying some of this stuff but but also
knowing that I've crafted it so it's not
just Reckless you know what I mean right
right yeah I'm really I'm really excited
about I don't 38 years in coming I don't
get that excited but I'm really excited
I'm excited for it too I I love that
you've made this return and then you
know you experienced a bunch of
resistance but now it's kind of gone you
know yeah just Mike just keep doing it
just keep doing it and now you're you're
doing [__] that's really being
recognized like you want to [__] Emmy
yeah I've got Grammy I got one Grammy
Grammy since I came back yeah yeah that
was nice it's nice and I think you won a
Grammy for the special this it was very
funny but I think the next one was I
think sorry was even better thank you
man I really do so I got nominated for a
Grammy so we'll see what happens I hope
it wins I'd love it if you want two
years in a row I want to see people get
crazy like [__] you know whatever [__]
whatever God damn it I loved it I got so
angry when people were calling out your
uh that leak set yeah and people are mad
because to me it was like that's what
he's always done this is great stuff
like not only that you hadn't didn't
stand up in 10 months I'm like this is
the this is the seeds of a fantastic
hour well you're only seeing like
literally the first couple of times he's
even said these things aloud in public I
literally was having a conversation with
another comedian and came up with the
bits and went on stage and did them so
it was the first time I'd done them and
I I just got so excited to be back on
stage because I had taken a long time
off and it was and there was is
resistance coming back but I was it was
I was in a club with my crowd for the
first time and so I was uh it was the
only thing I regret is it was Reckless
because my life was very in precarious
things were tough and things were tough
for my kids so that created a bigger
huge stink bomb than anything else that
had even happened yeah the set was
really really hard so
I I given how uh things were I probably
could have made jokes about a couple
other things I don't believe I did
anything wrong you did what you always I
do I've always done this the way it
works is I say stuff that is the wrong
thing to say I hear the resistance to it
and then I and then I work with it and
work with it and it takes a few shows
for it to be a safe bit to do but
there's a few audiences that that you
know and that audience actually didn't
didn't mind it but it's not for regular
consumption it's like watching somebody
practice piano yeah and going like he
sucks or or it's not it wasn't supposed
to the I think it's really bad that we
don't have these barriers anymore where
there's speech that's for these few
people there's speech we're gonna we're
gonna have a fun conversation where
we're gonna get a little crazy it's not
for the whole world to see well what was
infuriating to me was people that know
that they know what you're saying yeah
and they went after you I was like you
[__] [__] yeah there's people
that I won't talk to to this day because
of that wow I was like I'm not talking
to you like unless you want to make some
like big public apology or you want to
apologize to me and tell me why you did
it and what real feelings of insecurity
and jealousy but don't Dylan do that Tim
Dillon put a great post on his page
about what's really going on yeah he put
a great post on his Instagram and that's
when I became friends with Tim right he
wrote you're getting a bunch of people
that are mediocre comedians yeah and
that are attacking him not really
because of what he's saying but because
he's great and because they hate the
fact that he was getting any attention
at all and that should be theirs and now
they find some chance to move up in the
social structure yeah that that's what
it felt like to me all of that is
totally true and it's makes me
understand it in other words it makes me
feel sympathy it makes me go like
all right if that's what you need to do
that's what you that's what you got to
do it's it's uh I would prefer to hang
out with somebody who doesn't need to do
that but I get it and I can't be around
them because no I understand you can do
that again you can do that again you
know it's like having a snake in the
room like you can have a snake in the
room as long as I mean aside from my
[__] the thing that was a drag to me
about comedy in the last few years was
people who
any comedian who's out in the world
saying that comedian shouldn't be saying
these things yeah that's a traitor to
Comedy well they always started that's
not they're not a real comedian none of
them are good they've learned some
tricks so they can seem good and they
might have a big audience but they're
not they don't love this right and they
are that's a [__] up thing to do it's
a [__] up thing to do and it's always
coming from a place of jealousy yes and
also it's never it's always happening to
somebody who's already deeply besieged
somebody who's already the whole world
of course when you see the whole world
coming down on somebody for something
they said and then you go man me I'm
going to say the same thing exactly
that's about you that has nothing to do
with how you really feel about what they
said it has nothing to do it's just that
you want to be heard in your circle
saying it also because you see that you
can get a little something from it